hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in his essay how to seem virtuous
without actually being so Alistair
McIntyre is going to cre criticize a
point of view on moral education which
he readily
identifies as inspired by David Hume now
he will say a little bit later on this
isn't exactly that of Hume but it is
broadly humean and uh this is this is
identified as one which frames the
understanding of the virtues primarily
in terms of Pleasure and Pain Mutual
sympathy and shared conceptions of UT
and which actually stands in the way of
proper moral
development now he's going to be
criticized he sort of forecasts he says
the
characterization of this latter contrast
is bound to evoke two immediate
responses first it's unlikely that
anyone is failed to notice that what I
have characterized as the as the genuine
virtues are the virtues as understood
and practiced by the adherence of an
Aristotelian point of view McIntyre by
the time that he's writing this does
identify as an
Aristotelian uh you know later on
there's going to be some additions to
this atomist Aristotelian but he thinks
that basically Aristotle has things
right and he arrived at this through a
lot of thinking and study and dialogue
himself so he says um I'm presenting
that point of view and what I have
presented as counterfeit virtues are the
virtues as understood and practiced by
the adherence of a cian point of view
and so one criticism that you know he
imagines is going to get raised against
him is that he's actually engaging in
what we call question begging now I do
have to pause on this because the
meaning of this term has changed
somewhat in recent decades
so a lot of people will use begging the
question to mean leaving a questions
open not addressing certain questions
that is not what McIntyre means here
question begging in the older
traditional sense of the term is
actually a logical fallacy and it
consists in making
assumptions that are what your argument
is supposed to prove so question begging
is supposed to be a very bad thing to do
uh it shows that you're just coming from
a particular point of view that you've
already decided you've already got
preconceptions and interestingly enough
what is McIntyre's response to this he
doesn't say I'm not question begging and
here is why he actually says that um to
this accusation of question begging I
plead
guilty but it in no way affects the
principal point at issue so he's willing
to say okay you got me there but what is
the principle point at issue well the he
says suppose we were now to reverse the
terms of the
characterization and rewrite the chapter
from a hum standpoint treating as
genuine virtues those taken to be such
in a treaties of human nature one of you
know hume's most important works and as
mere duplicitous counterfeits the
qualities presented as virtues of the
nicam ethics except in so far as they on
occasion coincide with the virtues as
described and praised by Hume what would
happen if we changed things around that
way so he says well there are going to
be some constants that remain the same
no matter what first of all the two
theories are going to be different from
each other whether I beg the question or
don't beg the question whether I start
from Hume in a question begging way or
Aristotle in a question begging way it
doesn't erase the fact that these two
points of view are radically and
incompatibly different on what the
virtues actually are so he says the
extent and nature of the difference
between the two
standpoints the other thing that doesn't
change as he says is the theory taking
itself as correct so he says the second
is a matter of how the humean quite as
much as the Aristotelian is bound to
treat the virtues as prescribed by rival
views as
counterfeits now he points something out
that's quite important here and if you
want to know more about this particular
idea that he's got go to after virtue uh
this very important book that McIntyre
published in the early 80s um which will
talk specifically about this and you
could also look at who's Justice which
rationality which address es Hume at
greater length so he says Hume himself
it is true was blind to this supposing
as he did that agreement about the
virtues among mankind is in fact
overwhelming even if disguised by the
vagaries of social circumstance this is
why I call the position I've described
humean rather than Humes um so you know
Hume doesn't get that but a humi in the
present should say yeah Aristotle got
things wrong we humans have things
right and McIntyre is going to say you
know somebody could also point out that
you're not you're not addressing enough
you you talk about Aristotle you talk
about Hume but there's many other
conceptions of the virtues as well right
I've been arbitrarily selective and he
says there are it may be urged other
rival accounts of The Virtue virtues
deserving of equal attention yeah stoic
for example utilit Aran whatever and
then he says all right I'll grant you
that I could have talked about others
but here's the thing you bringing that
up that doesn't count as a criticism
against my argument that actually
strengthens the argument that I am
making here uh why in each case it will
turn out that serious and systematic
practice of what each such account takes
the virtues to be
presupposes and embodies the theory in
question so that each such Theory must
be understood as a theory articulating
and justifying one specific type of
moral practice each such type being in
key part incompatible with and
antagonistic to other such types so if
we took the stoics we would look at the
the virtues in ways that are sometimes
similar to how Aristotle does but also
in ways that are radically different and
we would say well the the arist Ian is
espousing some counterfeit virtues
senica actually says this about anger in
the book on anger prime example of that
and where McIntyre is going with this is
a claim that again he makes an after
virtue as well as many other places
there is no Theory neutral some some
perfect you know we're going to all the
theories will fit into this pref
philosophical not already engaging in
doing some philosophy and adequately
determined account of the virtues if you
want to understand the virtues and not
in a superficial way which we're going
to talk about in just a moment you got
to have a theory you got to do some
philosophy and it's got to be adequately
determinant it's got to say some things
that are actually giving you guidance
about the four key questions that
McIntyre raised early I in the work he
says the only account likely to be
presented in such a masquerade is the
thing that he's making a general
argument about will be the significantly
indeterminant usually tcid account
meaning silent account of the virtues
embodied in the rhetoric of contemporary
commonplace usage when people talk about
the virtues but don't really know what
they're talking about and don't mean an
awful lot by it but are making
essentially an appeal to us feeling warm
and fuzzy when we hear people talking
about bravery or Integrity or generosity
and we say oh great what does that
actually mean and then it gets very
vague after that so if we take on robust
substantive accounts these are going to
be Rivals to each other and mutually
antagonistic the hum
says the Aristotelian is wrong about
some stuff the Aristotelian says no the
humean is wrong about some stuff and
what are they differing on well the
accounts of what it is to have and to
exercise a virtue and McIntyre points
something out so we can have these
theoretical accounts and they are going
to be tied to ways of being forms of
communic
institutionalizations practices and
moral education so he says they require
as their social counterpart because we
exist in societies rival and mutually
antagonistic institutionally
institutionalized modes of moral
education and then he says all right
let's think about how
Aristotelian and humi modes of moral
education would differ from each other
so in all
cases it's going to involve learning to
distinguish genuine virtues from their
counterfeits their fact similes the
things that people say are virtues but
aren't really virtues so you know for
example if you think about David Hume
one of the uh virtues that people had
extolled prior to him which he says well
this isn't really a virtue it's actually
kind of a vice humility he calls it a
Monkish virtue right and he means that
it's actually not a virtue at all it
would be a
counterfeit um you know and we could
talk about how Aristotle views certain
things as not really being virtues even
though people praise them you know going
out on the battlefield and you know
running into people without actually
thinking about the dangers involved and
that's not really bravery that's fake
bravery that we call rashness or fool
heart right so this are the sort of
things that we're talking about how do
the different accounts differ from each
other well huge difference
between what sort of value what sort of
consideration we're supposed to give
pains and pleasures of other people the
humi point of view is really taking
pains and pleasures of others as being
particularly important he says a human
will want to inculcate in his or her
pupils a general responsiveness to the
pleasures and pains of others whatsoever
they are and more especially a
responsiveness to what in the social
life of his or own uh time and place is
such that others are generally pleased
by it or generally pained by it now the
Aristotelian is not going to say oh I
don't care about PL pain or pleasure at
all but they are going to take into
account uh what pleases or pains
different kinds of people so McIntyre
brings up several different ones The
Virtuous person The Virtuous person
functions as a kind of index what kind
of you know things should we take
pleasure or pain in by contrast to the
person at the other end the
vicious or the immature or the acatic
the person who can recognize what the
good is but doesn't do the good or
recognizes that things are bad but ends
up doing those bad things anyway they
take Pleasure and Pain differently Hume
and a humean perspective doesn't really
address that so that is a really
important difference here um there's
also going to be differences over the
role of practical reason you know you
may be familiar with hume's very famous
quip that reason is and can only be the
slave of the passions which is not
actually hume's full perspective it's
just something that sounds good but a
humean perspective does say that reason
is not enough to actually motivate Us in
the right way to moral Behavior to
developing and exercising the virtues
aristotelianism has a much greater role
and scope for properly developed
practical reason which depends to a
certain extent on the next big
difference maturity how do they look at
maturity for the humean not really that
important of a topic for the
Aristotelian absolutely important if you
read Aristotle's nican ethics there's
this rather uh strange claim that you
can't really teach ethics effectively to
younger people why not because they lack
the
maturity uh the life experience the
control over their passions that are
needed and Aristotle actually says
something that McIntyre reinforces here
some people are young in years some
people are young in their minds they are
immature as human beings even though
they've reached an age that we claim to
be maturity so he he you know talks
about this here training in the exercise
of practical judgment requires a
particular kind of appropri ation of
moral experience something unavailable
to the immature both by reason of their
lack of a sufficient range of
experiences and by reason of their as
yet insufficient training and
disciplining and redirection of the
passions and so he says that you know if
we look at our political leaders many of
them are quite immature in this
Aristotelian sense and he says what you
need to learn is how to conceptualize
and classify so that in Practical
reasoning one's descriptions of the
situations and issues on which Universal
moral truths concerning the virtues have
to be brought to bear are in the
appropriate form if you don't do this
lacking this capacity you're not going
to understand two things what
generalizations are appropriately to to
be brought to bear uh and in particular
situations nor how to generalize this is
the second thing from particular
experiences this is part of the
development of practical reason and it's
tied together with maturity ristian and
humans very different positions on this
sort of thing he also brings up uh
another issue the the theories are going
to have not only differences in the
theory but um and the content we're also
going to have to have an effective
background in order to practice them and
these are
important questions and McIntyre
actually suggests that you know if we're
going to be aristotelians we're going to
be at odds with uh liberal Democratic
capitalist societies and some of the
governing assumptions behind them uh it
doesn't mean we have to like go off and
live like Hermits in a commune or
something like that or all by ourself in
a cave but there's going to be certain
tensions there that may not be there
from a humi point of view right and then
he says it's also worth noticing at
least one example of the different
conception each view has of particular
virtues and he picks one that both Hume
and Aristotle think is really really
important Justice aren't they on the
same page they both think that Justice
is an important virtue to
cultivate but what do they mean by
Justice is the account that Hume is is
providing in his Masterwork the treaties
of human nature is at the same account
of justice as Aristotle is providing in
book five of the nican ethics and
McIntyre is somebody who knows them very
well and has taught them for decades and
written upon them says no it's it's not
the same conception at all says for the
artian justice is necessarily a matter
of desert and Merit dessert and Merit in
respect of contributions or failures to
contribute to the common life of a
political Community which through which
only human beings can achieve their good
through that Cooperative friendship
which is itself a central virtue and
then he says for a human it's not like
that at
all uh justice has nothing to do with
desert or Merit though for different
reasons and so he's not going to you
spell it out in detail here but you know
you're welcome to check out what Hume
actually has to say about this
and so he says that you know moral
education is going to be understood
quite differently in both cases coming
back to the maturity thing as he closes
out this section he tells us that moral
education for the
Aristotelian is going to have to proceed
through two different stages one of
these is going to require that
the aristotelians provide for the
education of their own Young from their
own point of view
and this is what what Aristotle has
provided for us what the young will have
to read for example will have to be
prescribed um there probably is going to
be a certain kind of censorship they're
going to have to learn how to not follow
their inclinations their instincts and
to move on transform their desires into
something better so he says like the
first stage of such education is going
to be one in which for Arista tians the
acknowledgement of the teachers
Authority on moral questions will be
crucial you have to do that and if you
don't do that you're not going to
develop as an Aristotelian so you know
what implications would this have well
we we need to appoint teachers on the
basis not just of their knowledge but
their moral character if we want to do a
genuine moral education now he doesn't
say how the humi would approach this but
you know we can say based on what we
know about Hume
that this is probably going to be less
of an issue for humans and it's
certainly not going to be an issue for
um people who are engaging in the
commonplace moral rhetoric that we've
been looking at in this article as well
so there's some pretty important
differences between an Aristotelian
point of view and auman point of view
both of which are substantive ethics
both of which are systematic both of
which which are not pre-philosophical
they're very much pre philosophical and
are rival versions of accounts of the
virtues and how reason works and what it
ought to look like in practice and you
know again McIntyre perfectly willing to
say that we are question begging to some
extent you know why because you can't
avoid it you have to embrace some
account or
incoherence or some superficial account
that doesn't actually answer anything
for you so he's endorsing an Arista
tilian point of view um but he points
out that even if you endorse another
stoic humean utilitarian you're going to
be embracing some point of view and you
have to still distinguish between
genuine virtues and their
counterfeits